look at these gen Z girls so cute
I want to do that Courtney Cox Rose to
Fame in the 90s but in her latest
Instagram video she's giving 100 gen Z I
like it yeah the 58 year old actress won
social media yet again when she posted
this video going full gen Z transforming
into an influencer
[Music]
[Applause]
Court totally nailed the vibe hair
makeup outfit even right down to the
selfies
[Music]
but plot twist court gets caught
he's home it's so much fun making vids
that get us talking is hardly anything
new for the friend star
[Music]
yeah Courtney her man Johnny McDade and
even their pal Ed Sheeran recently
showed off their dance skills
specifically their Dirty Dancing skills
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
moves a common theme for court
remember when she recreated the routine
from friends over 20 years later
[Music]
but long before court blew up our social
media feeds she stole our hearts on
screen with memorable roles in Scream
Cougar Town and of course friends you
ever had something that was so beautiful
that everyone wants it I have you
nice try I'm keeping the boots
all that work will be honored next week
when Court earns her star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame it's just it's
incredible I I'm I'm really honored I'm
excited cheers to plenty of professional
photographers being there to capture the
Milestone no selfies needed
what he's home
[Music]